all right leila
layla uh where'd you grow up where are
you from
i'm from phoenix arizona phoenix
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad um well when i was
around five i got i went into custody
with my grandmother what happened with
your family um with my mother she was
abusive towards me so yeah
what about your dad is he in your life
um no he's in and out of jail
how was uh how was your childhood with
with your grandmother
um i would say it was pretty all right
you went through high school
no i didn't i i dropped out around
freshman year
would you do that
um well i ran away from home when i was
14.
and started doing this kind of work yeah
early
yeah
how did you get interest introduced to
prostitution um from this one guy um i
met online
there's always this one guy
yeah
they're they're all over aren't they
mm-hmm
and so you started working the streets
yeah i started working the streets in
vegas you remember your first time yeah
tell me about that
um i had it was uh he posted me an ad on
back page
and then um the guy just wanted a blow
job and
that was my first date ever
white guy black guy mexican it was white
well he was actually armenian
and once you get over the
the
hurdle of uh doing it for the first time
this has become like oh that's how
that's all i got to do
and then the money starts rolling yeah
except you're not keeping it
i mean you can say that
so what makes a girl want to continue
with it if you're giving away your money
i mean for the elevation like
who doesn't want to elevate
so elevate means what to you
like
a better lifestyle yeah
because your
your dude will
your pimp will provide you with like a
roof over your head and clothing and
more than that though it's not just
about the that's the basic stuff it's
like
we're trying to get out of the game
how old do you know
i'm 21 years old i'm about to be 22.
i mean do you
do you see a way out you see that you're
saving money so you're gonna i do
actually
you're not spending it on drugs no i
don't do drugs you don't do anything
you seem pretty sober well i drink a
little bit but
do you have to drink to do this
sometimes yes i do
yeah i would
imagine doing this over
what's the hardest part of this
lifestyle for you um the hardest part i
would think um
i mean just dealing with different men i
mean
it's crazy you're developing quite a
skill set by having to interact with
this guy and then that one yeah this one
intimately mm-hmm and yeah the guys are
all different personalities yeah right
mm-hmm
you'll be able to use that skill set in
every any job you go to
not the sex part just right just the
interaction interacting with all these
people
how much money do you make in a night
in the night
in a day it depends like it's sometimes
it's slow sometimes it's good but
the quota a day is a thousand dollars a
thousand
rain or shine
you said what rain or shine
rain or shine if whether it's raining or
cold or oh yeah
sometimes it's slow when you make like
seven eight hundred dollars a night and
but i have a lot of regular stuff
that's good
do you have a pimp now
yeah i do you do
and it's a good relationship
it's fantastic
fantastic yeah
tell me about that
um he's a good dude like he's really
like
he's a good dude
takes care of you
yes he does
is he your boyfriend as well no he's not
not at all
so you're one of the few women that will
tell a positive story about having
a manager few
a lot of girls will talk horror stories
yeah well i had a fair share of guys
though
i think i think
the world of pimps is the most
has the widest range of
good to bad of any industry of any
career ever because you'll find guys
that are monsters and other guys that
are actually respectable
believe it or not
no one seems to want to believe that
but so your guy will
help you with what
well he's helping me well right now
we're like because i just barely started
messing with him so it's like it's a
process
but um he's already shown me things that
like i wanted to get done and stuff like
that
he teaches you how to
operate in the game without getting in
trouble
yes
he's just showing you a better
quality of life maybe yeah
did you have i mean if you were on your
own
would you
tell me how how do you think things
would be different i mean i used to be
on my own before i used to be a renegade
um
and i would think i was more lazy
i was more like
oh i could make the money tomorrow and
just spend everything today
i was more like that type so he's
helping you save money or yeah how not
to spend it yeah it's important
and you don't have kids right i have one
kid you do
is she with you
it's a boy a boy is he with you yeah i
have full custody
so you're not living in motel the motel
you're no you're staying an apartment
yes apartment with your child yes
for sure yeah
that's unusual as well
what what kind of emotions does doing
this kind of work bring up in you you
get
um i get depressed a lot i really do get
depressed i get like anxiety a lot
um because it's a lot
it is it's a hard thing for anybody to
do it is
yeah
you've had bad things happen to you out
there
i had a lot of bad things
but you stick out you stay at it
yes i do what kind of stuff has happened
um i mean
i think every
girl out there has been robbed i've been
robbed raped beat up
kidnapped yeah i hear that all the time
yeah
[Music]
your intuition probably eventually gets
so keen that you can
tell who's trouble
i mean you can but some people know how
to play that role right
you think you get desensitized to how
dangerous this lifestyle is
um most people would quit a job that
could get them robbed or right raped or
whatever i know but it's like
you know what we signed up for
at the end of the day yeah you think
you're addicted to it
addicted to the fast money
i think i am
what was the best example of a loving
relationship you saw when you were a
young girl
um growing up
[Music]
example like in my like your mom and dad
uh no
i don't think i really had a loving
relationship
have you been in love
[Music]
no well i can't say the only person i
love is my son so i'm sorry
i've been in love so
is this a lonely lifestyle for you
do you get lonely doing this
um
i would say sometimes i do
yeah i do
i mean spending time with a bunch of
strangers
it's like it's not exactly
the antidote for for loneliness
how does it affect your self-esteem
um well what a lot of people don't know
it's like i really have low self-esteem
so it's like
it's like it affects it a lot yeah i
mean even though the guys are rolling up
and telling you how beautiful you are
yeah and paying you for
sexual favors that doesn't necessarily
mean it makes you feel better
do you feel like you're selling yourself
short by by
doing this or
um you can see it you can see it
different ways
i don't think i saw i'm selling myself
short
you're basically having sex for a
hundred bucks roughly
um
no actually i charge that for a [ __ ]
oh you do yes you're more expensive than
me
um it's kind of like once you get it
it's like girls don't understand like
these guys really have more than what
they're saying like
if they say they have 60 they have 120
they have 150 like
now you can get in the car for 60 but
you should be coming out with like a
hundred dollars 120 dollars so you you
you lure the guy in you know
or you you
you get you get a date arranged with a
guy for 60
and then what do you do you say you're
talking oh like you stop in the middle
of the day like i need more money i need
more money like
you got to do what you got to do
do you think you believe in karma
i do believe in karma how does karma
play into what you do
it plays a lot into what i do
in what ways
i mean like if you're out here doing bad
things to people it's going to come back
on you do you feel like you're doing bad
things to people i don't harm people
yeah i know you're not but
you're not robbing him with a gun but
yeah i don't do that
of course but
what are some of the mistakes you've
made that you've learned from
um
about
messing with certain type of guys
or like like talking to certain type of
guys i've learned from that what are the
certain type of guys
um you know just like
your intentions like say if you're
talking to like a pimp
but you're you don't want to like go
with him you're just like talking to him
like that could really turn
back on you real bad so you can't even
talk to other
black guys right
no
what do you think the most misunderstood
thing is about girls that do this kind
of work
the misunderstanding is um
i actually don't know
like a lot of girls like do it for the
wrong reasons
like what
some girls do for hair nails lashes and
just
they're satisfied with that it's like
it's not the way at all
how do you think doing this kind of work
has changed you
um it's changed me a lot but i used to
be sweet innocent
um
i'm
totally not that anymore but
you become hardened a bit
is that because everyone you're dealing
with is
doing something
you have you have to have like a tough
you have to be tough out there
and that's not your nature
i mean i'm really like sweet but you
know
it changed me
how has this changed the way you see men
a lot
men are liars cheaters
i think all men are liars and cheaters
oh oh
yeah
is it difficult to be around so many
people that you don't trust
it is
because you don't know who's
gonna come at you next like it's got it
seems like it would be a hard lifestyle
you have friends
crazy thing about it is i have zero home
girls zero friends
that's not crazy i think a lot of girls
have told me that they don't have
friends yeah i have nothing at all
you get asked to do
risky things by some of your guys some
of the clients of course
what do you how do you handle that
go date somebody else because i'm not
doing good
you have dreams of doing something with
your life other than this
um well yeah i actually do
i have a game plan you do mm-hmm good
for you
you just feel you'll do this for a while
save some money and
um well now that i'm with my dude it's
like it's what i'm trying to achieve is
like i'm getting there more faster
it sounds like you might have a good
time
what advice would you give to somebody
else's a girl that's thinking of doing
this kind of stuff
thinking to do this yeah
honestly i would tell her not to it's
not even it's a headache it's a lot that
comes with it um
it's like a thousand other ways to get
money
what's the hardest part of it
of this yeah
i think the hardest part is having sex
with
man like
that you're just not attracted to at all
[Music]
yeah do you get guys that are just like
you just have to like
hold your nose and just
deal with it all the time some guys
think really really really bad and it's
just like
i can't do it what's the what's the
worst thing you had to experience
um i think a guy he had shitty draws
like
yeah and after that i when i seen it i
was like no we have to stop i'm not
doing anything else with you like
absolutely not
no
[Music]
what are the other girls on the track
what do you do you guys talk to when
you're out there sometimes
we do a lot of girls talk a lot of girls
socialize um you ever have problems with
some of the girls i've had multiple
problems with different females what
kind of what kind of things come up
i mean it's like some of the girls we
used to mess with the same dude and then
like you know one girl would get fired
and then she'll come back and have like
hatred to our jews like i didn't even do
nothing like
so that's a lot of issues and then some
girls get mad because you're talking to
their guy and then you don't want to
choose up with the guy and then some
girl be trying to fight you because of
that
it's very very competitive yeah
and the gangs are a part of the game
here in l.a yeah and uh
so you're you're pimp is gang-related or
no no he's not gay he's not straight
yeah
so when you hook up with a pimp i mean
your your child is with a
a pimp right
is is it always the case that you have
to have sex with your pen
um i mean
really i would say it's up to the guy
like to read so 100 because
a lot of guys don't mess with
their hoes like
it's just it's just a business yeah
arrangement
what are you afraid of most when you're
out there
um
actually the one thing i'm afraid of is
i have issue with a lot of well i have
and i want to say a lot i have an issue
with this certain guy out there in the
streets and it's like if he sees me it's
like it's over with like is it he's a
trick
no he's a um a wannabe pimp oh i see
yeah and he hassles you when he sees you
yeah every time
yeah there's lots of things to be
worried about when you're out there
it is is it safer in las vegas
i would say it's safer in las vegas the
guys are 10 times crazier over here
do you do you
steer away from certain ethnic
types i don't date black guys i don't
date puerto ricans puerto ricans is just
like black guys i don't
yeah at all because of why there's too
many games
it's too many games some of them be so
cheap and then then a lot of them want
to do the most for little
what was the best night you ever had
you ever have good things happen to you
the best night i ever had like the most
money i've ever made most money or most
fun or just just like um i think in
vegas in vegas i
yeah
vegas i make a lot of money
yes
so if your quota is a thousand here what
is your quota there
it depends in vegas because when you're
working the strip
you could make 1800 you can make twenty
five hundred you can make thirty five
hundred you can make fifty five hundred
it's like really different in vegas and
you don't work the casinos really you're
not you're not sitting at the bar
waiting for guys no i can't you can't do
that well i can do that um i'm 21.
but i've i've heard from some of the
girls you can't just sit there at the
bar you can can you yeah
if you know how to really play vegas
like not a random girl could just
you know because security be on yeah so
you can't dress like a prostitute yeah
you can't at all
you have to look like you're just a girl
that's that's going to the nightclub or
something right partying
and then how does it how does a guy pick
you up
um in vegas it's really different
because i'm figaro you could walk up to
guys cars and they already know what's
going on here in vegas it's like you
gotta like some guys are not even
looking for
a girl you just like have to bring bring
it to them
does your family know you're doing this
yes they do
my grandmother actually watches your
channel
say hi to your grandmother
how do they feel about it
um you know it's like every other family
they don't approve of it but they
they don't turn their backs on me
yeah i mean it's it's easy for someone
to judge girls that do what you do but
this is really just all about survival
yeah i think you just figured out the
most
successful way for you to survive
what about law enforcement
law enforcement um i mean that comes
with the game um i've been arrested
over 20 times 30 times
really yeah i probably got a warrant out
right now for me but
what happens when you get arrested
um
they take you in if you don't have no
warrants they release you in a couple
hours
that's it yeah that's it
some some states you have to do classes
and you have to take like hiv tests
did you get tested anyway yeah i get
tested all the time yeah
[Music]
and the father of your child is where
somewhere in l.a
is it just one of your tricks
hell no
he's a he was uh my ex oh i see him got
it yeah but he's not in the in your
child's life he's not
in my child's life
what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret
i would have to say
having i wouldn't say i don't know how
to put this but because i love my son
but
having a kid with
that type of person that's my biggest
regret
choose the partner you have have a child
with carefully is what you're saying yes
yeah or don't have kids at all trust me
being in the game is in a child
it's 20 times harder yeah and it'll keep
you in the game too
20 times harder yeah
and layla what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned
in your life
most um
i would have to say time
time is very valuable
it really is
all right layla thank you so much for
sharing sharing your story
i wish you the best of luck out there
thank you thank you very much
you